[Müzik]
Evet
ben Şeyda Betül Kılıç Herkese merhabalar
insan acılarını azaltmak için
azaltamadığımız hafifletemediğimiz insan
acıları olduğunda da onlara refakat
edebilmiş edebilmek için adanmış biriyim
psikoterapist diyorlar Siz böyle biz
böyle biliyoruz toplumumuz böyle biliyor
psikoterapist olmak bir çok acıya Eğer
alanınız benim gibi travmadan
insanı kendi kendine tanıtmaktan
geçiyorsa böyle size deneyimlerin içinde
bir yerden Mesleğinizi işinizi
yapıyorsanız insan acılarını temas
ediyorsunuz ve
uzunca yıllardır insanlarla birlikte
insan acılarının çok yakınında onlara
eşlik ederek zaman geçirmiş biriyseniz
de biraz acının kokusunu lisanını bir
insanın canının yandığında neye
dönüştüğünü yanmanın ne demek olduğunu
ve acıdan kurtulmak için
nelere başvurduğunu daha yakından
izliyor oluyorsunuz özellikle terapi
odaları
insanların Hocam bunu benden alır
mısınız Bunu nereye koyayım ya benim
burada bir yer yok Ve bundan bir an önce
kurtulmam lazım dediği bir yer ve İşin
garibi her seansta ya da her
bilgilendirme konuşmalarında bir kere
daha alsın çiziyorum
o acı sizinle olacak bir parça olarak en
azından bir anı parçası olarak sizinle
olacak çünkü onu içinizden başka koyacak
hiçbir yerimiz yok
insanlarla birlikte çalışırken insan
Acılarına temas ederken insanın acı
çekerken
koşulsuz bir şekilde kaçınılmaz bir
şekilde acı çekerken
kırıktan kılığa girerken
O acıyla bükülürken izlediği birçok yolu
görmek
Hakikaten bu deneyimin içinde olmak çok
ayrıcalıklı hissettiriyor Çünkü
hepimizde
çok derin insan acıları var çok derin
insan acıları var bazıları biraz
hafifletilebilir türden
hafifletilebilir
bakılabilir Ama bazıları başlar ve biz
ölünceye kadar bizimle birlikte bizimle
kalır
şu yüz yıl sonra ne yapıyorsunuz
Neredesiniz
Bu sorunun cevabı çok önemli
300 yıl sonra
kendinizle ilgili Yani bir kemik ve
iskelet kalıyor Bir de eğer şanslıysanız
ya da bir devlet sayesinde belki mermer
olabilir mezarlarınız daha saltanatla
olabilir sonunda bir şeyden bahsediyoruz
galiba ölüm hepimiz için kaçınılmaz en
büyük acı ve ölümlülüğün acısı
Bence ve benim bütün deneyimlerim ve
okuduğum birçok kaynağa göre
ölümlülüğün acısı bu dünyadaki bütün
acıların ve korkuların atası
Eninde sonunda neden korkuyor olursanız
olun hepimiz ölmekten korkuyoruz
ve hepimiz ölüme bir şekilde ya eşlik
ediyoruz yani ölmekte olan ya da ölüme
doğru yürüyen kişilere eşlik ediyoruz ya
da bunun da aniden karşılaşıyoruz ve
aniden karşılaştığımızda bunu bir yer
bulmak bununla ne yapılır Bunu nasıl
eşlik edilir ölüm eşliklisi olmak
Amerika'da şu anda çok daha moda biterim
ölüm eşlikçisi Olmak ya da bir acıya
eşlik eden biri olmak Buna da Şefkat
Elçiliği şefkatli biri olarak acının
yanında durmak diyorum
olabildiğince iyileşmeye dair yapılacak
her şeyin altında
acıya eşlik edebilme becerileri Biz
çalışıyor dikkat ederseniz
hepimiz uzunlamasına bir sürü plan
yapıyoruz bu 300 yıl sonra ne olacağını
bilmiyoruz ama o kadar uzunlamasına
planlarımız programlarımız hedeflerimiz
var ki adeta Hiçbirimiz ölmeyeceğiz ve
hepimiz burada kalacak gibiiz Evet
köklenme ihtiyacımızı biliyoruz
hepimizin köklenmeye ihtiyacı var uzun
uzun uzun öldükten sonra dair bile
hikayelerimiz var değil mi oraları bile
yönetmek istiyoruz öldükten sonrayı bile
yönetmek isteyen uzun vasiyetlere
rastladınız mı benden sonra evet
buraları bile yönetmek istediğimiz içsel
bir varoluş isteği var inanılmaz büyük
bir hayatta kalma isteği bir şekilde
kalmak belki
taştan Bir heykel olarak bile olsa olsun
bir şekilde var olmak bazı mezarların
üzerinde uzun uzun neden öldüğü nereden
geldiği vasfı unvanı falan yazıyor o
kişinin ya da o kişiyi sevenlerin onun
Yok olmasına ne kadar tahammül
edemediklerinin farkında mısınız hepimiz
böyleyiz Hiçbirimiz kaybolup gitmek
istemiyoruz bugün insan hikayelerinde ve
insan hazinelerin temasının altında en
önemli bir hazineden bahsedeceğim 2
hazine var bir tanesi insanın değerleri
onun hayatta tutan ne için Neden
sorusunun cevabı olan o harika
motivasyonel soru değerleri karşılık
gelen soru bir diğeri ise şefkat
Belki biraz şöyle biliyoruz
kendimizden başkasına verilen bir şey
Şefkat daha çok böyle biliyoruz Ben
çocuğuma Şefkat göstereyim acı çeken
Birinin acısını gidermek için orada
bulunayım Bu biraz daha bildiğimiz bir
şey
daha tecrübeliyiz ama
kendimizden Kendimize doğru şefkate
hepimiz çok yabancıciyiz çoğumuz çok
yabancı Ben acı çekerken Ben neredeyim
benim yolculuğumda ben neredeyim
hepimiz kaçınılmaz olarak acı çekiyoruz
şunu çok seviyorum Şu motoyu
hissedebilen Bütün canlılar çılgınca
acıdan korkarlar ve kaçarlar
fakat ve aynı zamanda
hissedebilen Bütün canlılar için acı
kaçınılmazdır
kaçınılmaz bir gerçek Öyle ise acı varsa
Şefkat de var çamur yoksa Lotus yok acı
yokse Şefkat yok ama acı hep var o zaman
Şefkat de hep var ancak onun varlığında
şefkatin bilgeliğinde biz Hayat bu kadar
zorlaştığında her gün belli kayıplar
verirken yeniden hayata başlamak zorunda
olduğumuz onlarca gün ve saat varken
tekrar ayakta oluyoruz yeniden hayatta
oluyoruz
bir yaramız var O bir kapıdır diyor
estess Çok sevdiğim bir yazar kurtlarla
koşan kadınlar kitabında
hepimizin derinde acıları var derin
kayıplar bize bu hayatta nerede
durduğumuzu neyin bizim için önemli
olduğunu birçok anıyla birlikte tekrar
tekrar çiziyor acı çekerken ve
neşelendiğimizde hepimiz aynı yaşta
oluyoruz hiç dikkat ettiniz mi
neşelendiğimizde bir yaştayız yani çocuk
bir yaş ve ağlarken de aynı yaşlardayız
ve hepimiz birbirimize neşeliyken ve acı
çekerken ne kadar benziyoruz bu ortak
Hikayemiz acı bizi ortak İnsanlık hali
sert kombation'ın yani şefkatin bir
doğrusunda topluyor Bu yazgı bu
bilinmezin içindeki bu acı bizim ortak
Hikayemiz ortak acımız
Evet
[Müzik]
çok bir çok zor bir zamanı Bugün sizinle
Belki bu kırmızı dairede Belki de
Hayatımda ikinci kez yazdığım bir kitap
dışında bir yerde bir sahnede ilk kez
belki paylaşmak mümkün oluyor çünkü
benim için de bir acıyı paylaşmak Tıpkı
sizin gibi
utanç veren bir şey çok zorlayan bir şey
o yüzden beni bilen tanıyan sosyal medya
üzerinden de bilenler işte ne bileyim
televizyonda şurada burada denk gelen
hiç kimse genel olarak bu kendini
derinliğini bilmezler Çünkü bunu
paylaşmak bir kaygı paylaşmak hepimiz
için olduğu gibi benim için de oldukça
zor ve tam şu anda
kendimi kendime olan şefkatinle
destekleyerek oradan aldığım cesaretle
buradayım Ancak böyle Kelimeler
birbirine eklenip belki cümleler halinde
cümleler haline gelebilir
bu çocuklar
biri benim çocuğum diğeri benim kız
kardeşimin kızı bu kazdıkları ve çiçek
ekmeye çalıştıkları mezardan Benim
rahmetli eşimin mezarı
Biz Evet Acı Ben hep acıyı hep
birilerinden dinlemiş terapistlerden
olmadım hep bu zor bir şekilde zor
deneyimlerin kenarından ortasından
geçmek gibi bir durum oldu bunu bir
kazanım gibi görmeye çalıştım başka yolu
yoktu çünkü
o 36 yaşındaydı Ben de henüz 30-31
yaşlarındaydım ani Ve tabii ki hiç
beklenmedik ölüme hazır olan var mı
sevdiği birini kaybetmeye hazır olan var
mı Elbette Ben de değildim ve ani birden
bir yerden çıkan bir arabayla
sıfır kusur bizde hiçbir kusur yokken
çocuklarım yaralandı eşim uzunca süre
yaralı bir şekilde kucağımda kaldı ve
çok da bilincimi ne yazık ki
bayılmamıştım o yüzden oralara ait
hoşuma gitmeyen Elbette acı veren Keskin
anılar ve kesitler var zihnimde benimle
kalsın istediğim şeyler asla bir yere
gitsin istemediğim Anılar Bunlar anı
kesitleri kötü mü Evet yaralayıcı mı
elbette ama hiçbiri bir yere gitmesin
istiyorum benimle kalsınlar istiyorum
Onlar benim için çok önemli
yaşanmışlıklar hikayemin çok önemli
parçalarını oluşturuyor
burada biraz durayım 15 gün sonra yani O
berbat araba'dan bir iki ölü
Çocuklarım ve ben yaralı çıktık Ben 15
gün sonra karnımda 35 zımba
dizlerimde parçalanmalar ve korkunç bir
şekilde uyandım
ve Evet ruhum çok yaralıydı ama
bedenimde yaralıydı kendim için de
endişelendiğim anlardı Çünkü hayatta
kalmak zorundasınız böyle durumlarda
hele de çocuklarınız da varsa
hayatta kalmaya çalıştım ben de herkes
gibi olabildiğince ve
vedasız bir şeydi o Yani biz iyi geçinen
bir Çiftlik ve Hani filmin en güzel
yerinde bittiği bir yer vardır her şeyi
toparlayabildiğimiz ve 14 yıllık bir
evliliğin iyi bir noktasında aniden bu
ayrılığın
sonucu olarak adaptasyon Benim için de
dünyanın en zor şeylerinden biriydi
ayağa kalkmak kolay mı değil ama
elimden geldiğince artık biraz daha
yasla biraz daha zaten travma
terapistiydim üzerine Ben de Kendim için
terapiler aldım herkes şey dedi Sen
maneviyatlı bir insana benziyorsun ya
daha çok dua et terapistlerde ne işin
var Buna gerek yok
spiritüel bay pas diyorum ben buna bir
insanın değerleri ilaç değerleri derler
Başka inanç değerleri başka olabilir ama
gerçekten yara aldığınızda hakikaten
kendiniz için harekete geçip yaranızı
dindirmek üzere yaratılmışsınızdır bu
elim acıdığında yandığında Diğer elimle
onu onarabilmek yardım edebilmek üzere
programlanmış bir şefkat motivasyonu var
bedenimde ve Ruhumda vücudumuzun bir
noktasında kanamalar olduğunda yaralar
olduğunda tüm vücut biyolojik olarak
orayı iyileştirmeye döner Bu da
biyolojik Şefkat kısmı mıdır kendi
kendine onarır ve insan Tam burada kendi
o içsel Şefkat bilgeliğiyle hayatta ve
ayakta tutabilir yaz tutmak Bu salonda
sevdiği birini kaybeden kaç kişiyiz
sevdiği birini kaybeder
Evet o zaman çoğumuz benzer
noktalardayız yani Hepimiz acıyı
deneyimlemiş Hatta
deneyimden anlamaya doğru gitmiş ve bunu
bilgeleştirmiş kişileriz o yüzden
ıssızının ne olduğunu ortak olarak
biliyoruz hatırlamanın ne olduğunu
biliyoruz bazen odaya Gelip şöyle
söylüyorlar hocam lütfen yani hiç canım
yansın istemiyorum
Neden canım yanıyor Çünkü çok özlüyorum
berbat bir şey bu
Peki sevdiğim birine özleme duygusunu
senden alsam bana verir misin
artık hiç özlemeyeceksin
hayır vermem
asla vermem neden vermezsin çünkü onu
özlemem benim için önemli bir şey Evet
çünkü özlemek
birine olan
tutkumuz ve bağımızın dışa vurumudur
özlemek önemsediğimiz ve değer
verdiğimiz kişiyle olan irtibatımızdır o
yüzden canınız Yansa da bazı acılar bizi
insan kılar bağ kurmamıza yardım eder O
yüzden neyden kurtulmak istediğimize
bazen bakalım Ben şu an Hangi acıdan
hangi motivasyonda kurtulmak istiyorum
Gerçekten istiyorum biriyle özlememeyi
asla hatırlamamayı o günler hiç
yaşanmamış olsunu Gerçekten istiyor
musunuz yoksa bir yerde Evet kesen Evet
kanatan bir hatıra bile olsa ne kadar
güzel ne kadar değerli ve bana belki
Yüzümü gülümsetmese bile çok şey öğreten
günlerde yaz o yüzden yaz tutulmaz
yasla yaşanır yaz bir
Pro sestir hayat boyu bize eşlik eder O
yüzden Bu salonda Eğer bu kadar
kalabalık sevdiği birini kaybeden
kişilersek
İşte o zaman şunu hepimiz biliyoruz yas
tuttuk ve bitti değil bir parçamız kırık
bir parçamız daha yaralar var ve İşte o
yaralar Bizim için en büyük insan
hazinesi Çünkü bizim için yaşanmaya
değer ağlamaya değer sevinmeye değer
hikayeler oluşturmamıza yardım ediyor O
yüzden hepsi böyle belki nesilden nesile
ne kadar değerli olduklarını
aktardığımız çok güzel Yollar Peki
buralardan nasıl çıktık ne yaptık kendi
deneyiminden Evet berbat bir deneyimdi
ayağa kalkmak ve yoluna devam etmek için
hayatında tam ortalarında bir yerlerde
Belki şimdi başlarında sayılabilecek
yaştaydım Benim için çok zor
Sonrasında hani çok sevdiğim birinin
cenazesine gidemeyeceğimi hiç
düşünmemiştim Mesela yani genel olarak
sevmediğiniz birini bile Gider
bulunursunuz insan böyle düşünmüyor
planladığı şey asla bu değil o zaman ani
kayıplar var ve Her biriniz her birimizi
bir anksiyeti olarak söylemiyorum bunu
bir hayat gerçekliği olarak
kaybedebiliriz insan ölümle
karşılaştığında en yakıcı şunu
deneyimler
kaybedebilen biriyim
kaybedebilen olduğunuzu fark etmek Çünkü
bizim için niye kaybedeyim ki kaybetmem
yani Hani her şey elimin altında gibi
ama ölümse bir şeylerin bize
kaybedilebilir olduğunu gösterir Evet ne
yapıyorsan sadece onu yaparak
gördüğünüz gibi bağlantılar kurmak
birbirimizin yerine geçmek birbirimizin
yanında olmak müthiş ve çok değerli bir
şey Van Gogh'un hayatımızın en değerli
hazinesi anılarımızdır dediğini
hatırlayalım anılarımız bazıları acıtan
bazıları kesen Anılar olabilir ama her
birine dönüp baktığımızda anıların bizde
bıraktıklarıyla bilgeleşmek ancak mümkün
ve ölümün bizden alamadığı bir şey var
O da anılarımız bu sulakuyu ne çok iyi
bir çok güzel bir notu var diyor ki
görebildiğiniz şeylere tahammül edebilme
gücünü şefkatten alıyoruz
yolda Hayat bir yol Yürüyoruz ve çok şey
görüyoruz birçoğu hiç tahmin etmediğimiz
şeyler dayanamayacağımız şeyler
görüyoruz son dönemlerde Bu çok oldu
özellikle gördüklerimize dayanabilme
gücü içsel olarak kendimize yönelik
şefkatimiz kendimize yönelik verdiğimiz
güçle ancak Hayat tahammül edilebilir ve
burada kalınabilir bir motivasyon
sağlıyor birbirimize şefkatimizin olduğu
gibi acı çekerken kaybettiğimizde
kaybedebilir olduğumuzu fark ettiğimizde
kendimizden Kendimize Doğru da Şefkat
verebilme potansiyelimiz olduğunu
bilelim
kendimize hizmet edebilmeyi ve kendimizi
ayakta ve hayatta tutabilmeyi diliyorum
teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]